hello everybody my name is mark blar and
i'm back with the mortuary assistant
there is a basement in this game and
there's a way to get into the basement i
just don't know what it is
but i imagine that it occurs after
this there is no guide available on the
community hub and steam to get to the
basement and i have not dug any further
and i don't want to dig any further i
want to dig into the basement so that's
exactly what i'm going to do i wonder if
there's anything supernatural that
happens in here also what era is this
the tech does seem a little old
grandma
[Music]
i feel like there's got to be a way to
get into the bathroom that doesn't seem
to be also is there no bed in here
is this the bed
is this all there is
that's kind of sad it's a dinko
apartment
real dinko okay
sit there
so there i know there's a padlock on the
basement door
i just have to find the key that gets to
the padlock i'm assuming that everything
else here is going to be exactly the
same
if not well i'm screwed
so we'll see what happens
oh
achievement apparently that was worth
achieving
matchbox i didn't do anything with the
matchbox
i have to imagine that some things are
going to be really small and well hidden
so i just have to find where they are
and what they are and then i'll know
i never had the power go out to the
point i needed to do anything with a
fuse box
well
time to get to work
i'm assuming that it's going to be
relatively similar
at least i can keep track of things
that's open
i wonder what this is about this has got
to be something here there's got to be
it's got to be something important they
wouldn't just have that there it's
written in
it must be something
turbo
um
i don't know what that did probably
nothing well might as well get the first
body then unless there was something on
the back of my card there might be
something on the back of a lot of these
cars
my work to badge
extra keys
extra keys to the mortuary but which
keys i really need a key to the hatch
outside cleaners low and you mentioned
having some down there before i know you
don't trust anyone to go down there but
having a copy of the key would make
things a lot easier for everyone so
there's got to be a key
somewhere here
or if there's not
oh man i don't like that
oh that's not good
okay
that's fine not like that
sherwood harold
laverne knight and sam burton
is there anything in these
other ones
why shut up don't do that
don't do that ooh what if i
hmm
wasn't this a thing
i now have ashes but where can i use it
ash's remains from scrape from the
retort item cannot be dropped so that
must be important
right
so that lady always appeared here
that's not it
that's not it
there's got to be something here
but the only thing i know is to just
start processing bodies so i'm going to
do that i'ma leave these open just in
case something happens i don't know
hello
welcome to the party i've already
forgotten your name i apologize for that
but it is the way it is are you smiling
i don't like that
i don't like that why you gotta be like
that
oh
hello who is that why was that i didn't
like that did you like that i didn't
like that
okay sherwood
let me process your information real
quick it's going to be painless because
you're already dead so it doesn't really
matter
okay not smiling anymore
you just have a sunny disposition
oh i don't have the notepad let me go
grab that
god that's no whoa
hey that was early
interesting
oh boy
oh
aha we got
sonic all right sonic
sonic good good good
i hate this i hate everything about this
i hate everything about where i am
currently
there's that shine that goes on my
headphones and it's just like it catches
my eye looks like something's behind me
i don't like it
there we go
all right now we clean it
okay whoa
whoa what's happening what's happening
oh hi
oh where'd you go oh
oh what's that about
hello what are you pointing at
what are you pointing at what are you
pointing at what are you pointing at oh
i'll take that don't worry
ah
interesting
the year of arrival of the house of
death the birth of its creator the full
number shall be six
uh
interesting the full number shall be six
what does that mean clearly that's a
puzzle and clearly there are still new
things happening
the year of arrival of the house of
death the birth of its creator the full
number shall be six okay so 1970 is when
i'm assuming house of death is referring
to the the mortuary itself
god i don't like this okay so we've got
1970 the year of arrival of the house of
death which is the first thing the birth
of its creator so the creator is this
dude
samples 1970 and then his
why are you closed
i don't like it hello
so the birth of its cr creator excuse me
moral keys can i please have those
okay we got april 17th
so that's 04
17 1944
okay
so its number shall be six one two one
five is that the access code for the
website let me just
punch that in real quick
well that's not really helpful for me at
least it's unlocked now
okay so i need cleaner i need tank
cleaner i was interrupted
on the way to the bathroom
okay so if it's
the year of arrival of the house of
death the birth of its creators full
number shall be six so we've got 1970
and then april 17 44.
it could be 7
70
17 44.
wait
whoa
[Music]
oh
no thank you
i just remembered something i saw in the
previous
video
there is a code back here
is this what it's for be six let's try
17 70
17 44.
let's try
04
1744
nope
okay so that's seven
keys that needs seven numbers what is
that for numbers shall be six doesn't
make a lot of sense
i'm not 100 about that one
all right you're all good to go
hope you had a good time i know i did uh
have a good eternal rest
um
don't get possessed by any demons and uh
have a good time
[Music]
all right well that wasn't open before
hey wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute you're you're an eager
beaver here
just you wait your turn
oh did you just smile oh good you're
excited
me too
i can't wait oh big award-winning smile
yep
what a job laverne
so there's a numpad underneath
ah man i don't know if it's like an
order of operations thing where i need
to get the number first or
also let me scribble okay
that's nice yeah i don't know if it's an
order of operation things where i need
to get the number first or if the number
is something
whoa
oh
okay we got a
high booby what was with the knocking
i don't like the knocking all right
let's take care of that smile
my what big teeth you have
there we go
still smiling
out demon
out demons
demons
oh okay
all right time to fill her up
rebecca ooh
what what is that what is that about
what is that about what is that what is
that about what is this about
what
what
what what is it what is it
what is this
mom
okay um
oh boy
okay
oh boy
hello stupid [ __ ] oh that's mean
hate me all you want
he's dead because of you oh well i don't
know about that you should be the one
here well i don't know about that okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say it's
strange that there is a painting of this
lady who has been appearing all over the
place here in the mortuary because that
seems like um
seems kind of like a recipe for disaster
i don't know about this guy who does all
this stuff uh but it seems to be well
it's here i
guess the first
where was that
oh i forgot to add in t booby we got
double t or pi booby we have pi booby
and then double t we're really moseying
on these aren't we i was not done with
this by the way
you interrupted a very delicate process
there we go
mm-hmm i gotta clean
oh boy what is it now
hush
hush hush you've been taken care of you
had your turn
enough enough
enough
oh
hey
wow okay
oh
what
i just got doodle of it
a conor copia
okay
no it's so happy
well no thank you starting to suspect
starting to suspect a low
no
oh
hey
okay
interesting um
fascinating actually if you really
think about it i just moisturized you
why you got to be mean
all right let's go
[Music]
i'm making record time i'm thinking this
might be the demon body
seemed uh pretty obvious to me but uh
what do i know i'm just an assistant
okay
all right sam
all right
so what happened to you sam huh
you uh have a bad run in with something
or other
you have a bad day
don't worry i'll take care of you
i'll take real quick
i won't who said that
rebecca
interesting
interesting
very interesting hello
uh-huh
oh god oh no oh no oh no oh no
well it's oh god oh my god oh my god
oh god please don't
i do hey okay i'm here now
well that was fun i'm glad that happens
i'll do a sketch no
no no new name
guess i just got to take care of this
body
all right what's wrong with you come
down here
uh
where
oh my god it whoa whoa come down
what
the hell
what
oh
no so
little raymond thinks he found a
replacement
oh my god another sacrifice to save his
[ __ ] skin
you seem like a little bit of a [ __ ]
there
pal
oh i hate you guys
oh wow i don't like you
hey what's up oh what
what oh it's a puzzle oh it's a puzzle
why is it a puzzle
why is it a puzzle
oh god okay nine okay wait nine okay
this is part of the puzzle it's it's the
uh
it's what it was the the thing was
saying
you don't have anything on you
ah you don't have anything on you
okay
almost got scared by my own
self so i need to
do this in order of the numbers 1970
1944
one
key
interesting
that's weird wait
oh god did i do that wrong wait no i was
just opening mouse oh no
oh no
four
yeah interesting
hey oh my god no thank you hello
okay you had the key
so that's good
[Music]
what's in all uses mal this is
interesting
i'm guessing this is just an endeavor to
not waste time but here i am wasting
time so the second one is seven no third
one seven
seven or is that a lie
or was it just trying to see which
would have saved me time to know which
one was
supposed to be where i think
i think anyway
i'm just doing this to do it
oh my god why am i doing it to do it i
don't know
oh so the one so one one is correct and
the number shall be seven
or six
oh hello hi oh that's a fun one
oh hello hi
okay
what if i go that way
what if i don't
oh what if i don't what if i look around
a bit
okay i won't
i'll go to the grave
oh ow well that's not my grave what is
happening here
oh hi
i'm sorry
uh okay
good thing i still have the paper in my
hand
wow
weird i don't know what that was about
that was bizarre
i feel like i didn't do that right
there was some kind of a code and i did
get a key and it got me through the door
but i'm not sure
i don't have a key
anymore
okay
weird
where even was i
it's marking down
[Music]
things on your stupid face
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wait that's gone
wait a minute why is it gone
why is that not there anymore that was
there
that
that was there
i must have done something wrong i feel
like i've done something wrong
i feel like i did something wrong
okay
it's your grandma
hi grandma
hey
oh you got it
okay how
how do i uh
how do i do that grandma
i do i really do i do and i'll be right
out
[Music]
oh good i need that i thought maybe you
could
slit your wrist for me oh that's a tall
order
what's wrong rebecca
don't be afraid of your grandma
whoa okay
okay
thanks grandma
oh
frick maybe i should have paid attention
more to those numbers because that oh
that would have given me the code to
this thing
i don't know
i should have written down those things
on the heads i should have absolutely
written down
but i didn't because i'm some kind of
dumb
but i thought there was only six yeah
that doesn't make any sense either that
was six
and i think it had to do with
the birthday thing i don't think that's
pertaining to that
i don't think anyway
uh oh
that's fine
how's my sanity ah it's back to the
penis
[Applause]
oh where are you oh
ah the doom slayer
perfect all right we got ourselves a
doom
oh hello what was that i didn't even see
it what was that
[Music]
which door
which are you talking about
hold on
okay so sonic pie boob
or umbrella and doom slayer
sonic pyboob umbrella doomslayer
uh-huh here we go so pi sonic
pysonic umbrella doomslayer so that was
the order but i didn't have it right
so
it's a pie sonic
umbrella
okay um
yeah uh are you done
are you done so
okay
[Music]
oh
oh no don't do that don't do that no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no no no
oh no no
no no no no no
no
i don't wanna i don't wanna i just don't
wanna i don't wanna and because i don't
wanna i'm not gonna
i'm gonna oh my god i'm gonna
don't kill me
i can't hold anything else
i've got a mark i don't need the mark at
the moment
can i put it back
good i don't think it's this body
doesn't seem quite right you know what i
mean something i'm missing something
why is this door closed
okay that's more like it i need some
fresh air in here you know
there we go
okay cleaning time
i'm still not closer to getting into the
basement i feel like that cutscene got
me into the basement
what was that
there was something that happened
that sounded like
the basement
no
that's not it that's not it i can't use
that here moisturize
okay
oh
my
god
oh
my god okay great
good
why you just giggling is that all you're
doing
so it's definitely not this body all
right i know that
so it's got to be one of the other ones
i think it's that middle one well not
middle one this one i think it's you
you were the one that curved up like a
pretzel i don't even i don't know if i
have to burn
when i get there or before
i don't know when i need to do the burn
that's the question that i have
but i don't think it's this dude i think
it's that one
[Music]
it's you isn't it oh
yeah that that looks
oh my god
oh no
oh my god i can't see
oh
[Music]
yeah you know all curved up like a
pretzel like that i'm starting to think
that maybe you might be the
one
um i'm gonna go get uh
we'll go get me a
a thing
you know and then maybe i could just pop
your oh god no please not like this
hold on like this
oh not like this
i like this
oh
do i go around oh god okay i'm gonna
just
we're taking you back here uh
seems like you might be
suffering from some demonics
weird a little weird i don't have the
the mark
so uh i don't know if
i don't know if i was supposed to bring
it in here um
oh boy am i good are we good good night
okay
wait were you pointing somewhere you
weren't pointing somewhere were you
you weren't pointing were you
no no no no
no
no way
oh hey
okay
don't like that
uh taking this
what's going on
what's the deal what's the deal what's
the deal
weird high-pitched humming
some grownage
oh i think i gotta plop him back in
[Music]
okay
i can't use that here what why not
he's literally twisted up like a pretzel
what else would i do i can't use that
here
what do you mean i don't know this is
very strange
now let me put these guys away for a
moment
why can't i uh
[Music]
i can't use it i can't use that here
where could i use it is he all curvied
up which means that i can't
oh you would get oh
what's with the groaning
that's a significant groaning
very weird
very weird
very weird
very weird i don't like it i don't like
it it's tyler blasting his horn from in
space with markiplier
i don't know i don't know i don't know
i'm freaked i'm freaked i'm freaking and
i'm freaked maybe i gotta slap this one
up to the burner and then cause i know
you're the burn one if you're not the
bird one this is quite a trick you know
this is quite impressive
can i use the mark
why can't i use that here
what if i pop you back in your tube and
then
close the door would you uh
you know
relax
oh he's not gonna relax
he's not gonna relax well this is a
problem i can't use that here
i can't even pop him on here anymore
i think i broke it oh god i broke it all
right you know what
oh don't fight me don't fight me don't
fight me hard days work
well done i'm going home
oh tired gonna get a freaking nap
it's gonna
i'm good thanks
am i just sitting in here to chill
what is that about what is that about
what is semi being abducted
i don't know i'm really trying but i
think it's borked i can't pick them up
anymore make try picking up another body
i don't know
okay i got one
i could use a mark on him
what do you mean
oh
i don't know i don't know
uh the humming's getting real hum
delicious
oh really is this the time okay there he
is
i can't use that apparently
i don't know okay you're pointing to the
right which means it must be that one
over there right
that's the idea is that what you're
saying i'm just gonna burn that body
then
let's put you in here because otherwise
i think i'm gonna get exploded here you
go buddy oh it just used it i can't use
that here it just used oh cause it was
the gurney right right right
all right here you go pal i don't know
why but
this is the only thing i can do so i'm
gonna burn you and i'm probably gonna
get the wrong answer but whatever here
we go wham
there's nothing i could do i wouldn't
put it on the twisty pretzel man
so this is just what i did and it's
probably wrong
[Music]
i got it ryan
good morning
it's nice not to be the one down there
for a change
raymond i suppose a first name basis is
an order
did i make it is it over
for now
it's never really over
you've come a long way
it's a lot to learn
i'm so glad i'm here
i know it's disorienting
you'll get used to it
you should head home and get some rest
every night can be different
i
think i'm fine
are you sure
you seem out of it
oh i've just been waiting
for so
so long what
what are you oh oh no
you chose the wrong body
rebecca rebecca's not here you [ __ ]
idiots
watch
[Music]
okay
i
didn't think i got it right i don't know
why i exploded into a fiery soul
explosion yeah i thought i thought i
thought so but it didn't seem to want to
let me do it to the one that was all
twisted up like a pretzel it seemed like
i wanted to do that but it didn't work
so
you know
but anyway i'm still not in the basement
which means that i gotta try
again it is crazy that there's still new
stuff to be uncovered here
like there's two or three more endings
and i know one of them has to involve
the basement so i'm going to do this
again
probably still in night vision thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below
more spooky games coming at you very
soon and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
it's spooky and dark i'm getting out of
here
[Music]
you